hey guys Joey here with once again
another unboxing and today we're gonna
be doing the Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
collector's edition interesting fact
this is actually my own personal copy
that I bought myself and let me know and
this is the most expensive video game I
will probably ever purchase in my life
it's $200 but it does come with a lot of
stuff in it comes with the deluxe
edition of the game for statues and also
six six of the Infinity stones so let's
open it up you gonna need some help
okay I'm going vertically this time oh
okay that's that is a very big box there
and then on the back here you can see
the statues as well as the family stones
that comes with we've got Captain Marvel
Iron Man chun-li and Mega Man X this
baby open so on the top here we have a
couple of warnings says a fragile
packaging and over here it's interesting
because it looks like they're telling
you exactly how to hold the statue not
from the body but by the base meanwhile
we have the looks like we have the
position of the game right there so it's
a steelbook
that includes all DLC for the next six
characters I believe and also since is a
PlayStation exclusive comes with a
special Captain Marvel update so let's
get into the the meet this box
[Music]
okay there you go
oh there you go you actually got this I
believe this is the premium packaging
that the game or the box is telling us
about it's a Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
logo etched into the styrofoam I like
this actually I might actually keep this
alright oh boy let's lay this down real
quick
whoa that factory fresh smell alright so
there's a fourth of statues oh stop with
Iron Man actually
so first up Iron Man there oh don't grab
it by his legs grab it by the base all
right that's one go go Captain Marvel so
I think according to what my coworker
said we can actually connect this right
here
Oh kinda kind of kind of fits you can
see the cracks line up slightly so those
would be right there
keys well there's actually some really
good in a new job going on some of these
alright next up is the shuttle nice
statue again by the base not the legs
[Music]
rubber it's just she's she's standing on
her very tiptoes right here so it was
probably like a steel beam going through
her leg finally get a Megaman X right
here so let's connect them all there you
go we got a fierce battle going on right
here alright
hold on let me put Megaman in front no
they don't quite they'll clip in but you
can kind of a push them towards each
other they kind of like fit together and
like kind of like how the world was once
Pangaea just like this continental drift
okay the last thing that we have in here
is the are the Infinity stones and they
come in this little case right here see
them kind of look like Easter eggs
that's good right people like those in
games all right up looks like we will
need a screwdriver all right
[Music]
batteries oh that's right there in here
[Music]
think so all right hit the lights
oh they glow
no it's just uh it's on or off
nope they are stuck in there there and
they're good lights the game yeah all
right we got the steelbook featuring the
villain Ultron Sigma uh uh okay so we
got the the disc version of the game it
comes with the game as well as the
character pass which includes the next
six DLC characters they'll be released
throughout the next year and see up
here's the costume that comes with the
ps4 version the Captain Marvel often
right there and I believe that does it
alright and that was it for the Marvel
vs. Capcom infinite collector's edition
we have statues Infinity stones and the
game itself which is again wonderful for
me personally I'm actually really happy
with this you know I really like the
statues and the game it's the best but
what do you guys think if you have any
you know comments about this just leave
it down below and we will see you guys
[Music]